Enfin, nous sommes passés à l'offensive
j'espère qu'on va continuer comme ça
Je pense juste comment ça va continuer
nous nous arrêterons aux frontières de ceux qui étaient avant
Le 14, nous rendrons aussi Krym
[musique]
c'est une sorte de fantasme. Comme moi, je le fais absolument
ne croyait manifestement pas à la victoire militaire
l'Ukraine, mais maintenant je suis
en le regardant, je me suis rendu compte que
beaucoup apparu
hommes parce qu'il me semblait que cela suffisait
mammifères Et nous avons un vrai homme, mais je
Je suis très, très inquiet pour eux
Nous nous battons depuis plus d'un an et nous sommes prêts à
ceci a suivi ceci
notre victoire
On ne parle pas encore d'elle, mais on l'a déjà
nous obtenons pour cela, nous avons payé le sang et
la vie de nombreuses personnes, les meilleures personnes, et nous
nous obtenons ce que nous méritons ce que nous sommes
ont remporté cette victoire pendant toutes ces années